what's a neural network like what oh
yeah so a neur a neural network is
actually describes our brains uh the
neurons uh that fire in our brains with
synapses and how I mean way of thinking
of it is in our minds we have these
things called synapses which are a
little nerve endings and they connect to
each other and ideas are formed when
what is it um uh synapses that fire
together wire together and so um you
would when you see uh your your your
your mother um you can recognize your
mother's face in a particular region of
the brain and you recognize all the
different things and memories come
flooding back into you and you can do
that all the time and even when you're
not seeing your mother but you're
thinking of your mother with an uh MRI
machine we can identify the same part of
the brain uh firing okay so we
understand that these are these neurons
where memories are stored as
well